Some months ago, we published a Biographics
on Italian WWII navy commander Junio Valerio
Borghese.
Many of you asked us to cover more military
protagonists from the Italian side of the
Axis alliance, as they get less attention
than their German counterparts.
Here we are today with someone who we feel
may satisfy your curiosity.
Today’s protagonist was an Olympics-level
horse rider, a ladies’ man, a cavalry officer
of three wars, a guerrilla fighter, and a
secret agent.
This is the story of how Baron Amedeo Guillet
became the ‘Devil Commander’ who waged
a private war against the British Empire in
East Africa.
The Early Wars of Baron Guillet
Baron Amedeo Guillet, was born on February
7th, 1909 in Piacenza, northern Italy, from
an aristocratic family.
Following in the footsteps of his family’s
tradition, Amedeo enlisted at the military
academy, graduating in 1931 as a 2nd Lieutenant
in the Cavalry.
Assigned to a Light Horsemen regiment, he
impressed his superiors with his horse riding
skills, so much so that he joined the Italian
horse riding team for the upcoming Berlin
Olympics of 1936.
As a young and dashing officer with a perfect
‘stache, Amedeo became renowned also for
other successes: ladies could not resist him,
and he was rumoured to have dated Hollywood
actress Mary Pickford, among other celebrities.
But Olympic training and romantic affairs
would soon give way to another calling.
In the Summer of 1935, Guillet was ordered
to the Italian colony of Libya, to train a
squadron of Spahis, local mounted troops.
Guillet soon realised that these riders, whom
he described as ‘splendid’, needed little
training.
In fact, he had a lot to learn from them.
It is not clear whether Guillet knew he was
going to lead the Spahis into battle very
soon: the war with Abyssinia was around the
corner.
What he did realise, though, is that to properly
lead them and earn their respect, he had to
speak their language.
Guillet decided to learn Arabic by joining
a local Quranic school, alongside children
less than half his age.
As it turned out, Guillet had a talent for
learning languages, and very soon he was able
to communicate with his soldiers.
He would perfect his Arabic in the following
years, an ability that would eventually prove
handy.
In October 1935, Mussolini ordered the invasion
of Abyssinia, following a border incident
with Eritrea, an Italian colony.
Emperor Hailé Selassié denounced the act
of aggression to the League of Nations, but
it resulted in little action or support from
the Western powers, save for an ineffectual
trade embargo against Italy.
With the start of the war, Guillet could have
asked for a relocation to the motherland,
thanks to his scintillating credentials, but
he asked instead to be assigned to the front.
After two months of little action, it was
time for Guillet and his Spahis to engage
the enemy at the Battle of Selaclacla, on
Christmas Eve 1935.
At that time, he was suffering from a bad
bout of malaria -- he was so drowsy and feverish
that he had to rely on his Spahi sergeant
to spot incoming enemies on his behalf.
This is how he took notice of an incoming
Ethiopian rifleman, whom he shot with his
pistol, his first kill in combat.
The battle soon turned into a melee, and another
Ethiopian tried to tackle him off his horse.
Guillet struck him on the head with the hilt
of his sword, knocking him out cold.
Immediately afterward, a bullet came flying
toward his stomach; fortunately for him, it
hit the pommel of his saddle and ricocheted
through his left hand.
As the war dragged into 1936, Guillet was
able to experience first-hand the horrors
and iniquities of modern colonial warfare.
Official historical sources still differ on
whether the Italian Air Force dropped poison
gas canisters on Haile Selassie’s troops
or not, but we have Guillet’s personal,
eye witness account.
He did witness at least one such aerial gas
attacks during the campaign.
Not only did he find it a dishonourable and
inhumane way to conduct an offensive, but
he also observed that in most cases, it was
ineffectual against an unentrenched, highly
mobile enemy such as the Ethiopians.
Guillet found his own way of fighting to be
the most honourable and effective: a horse,
a sword, a pistol.
And a perfectly trimmed moustache.
When on the May 5th, 1936 the Italians conquered
the Ethiopian capital of Addis Ababa, Guillet
was not there to celebrate -- he had been
ordered back to Tripoli for a delicate assignment.
The Duce was due to visit Tripoli, as the
colonial authorities needed a skilled horse
trainer for an elaborate propaganda stunt:
the ceremony of the ‘Sword of Islam’.
After reviewing Italian and colonial troops,
atop a splendid white horse, Mussolini would
solemnly unsheathe a scimitar for the benefit
of newsreels.
The ceremony‘s meaning was to portray Italians
in Africa as natural allies of the Muslim
populations against other colonial powers.
The ceremony was a success, but Guillet’s
hand wound got infected and worsened over
time, so he was sent to Naples to undergo
surgery.
After the operation, Guillet spent time recovering
with his relatives, the Gandolfos.
Among them, his childhood best friend and
favourite cousin, Beatrice.
People at that time should have known better
than to leave an aristocrat and a cousin alone
in the same room: it very often led to much
beseeching, swooning, hand kissing and other
euphemistic activities.
The only thing that stood between the union
of Amedeo’s and Beatrice’s trembling lips
was a pair of expertly groomed whiskers.
But those, I am sure, were more of a facilitator
than an obstacle.
But hey, I am not judging: different times,
different habits.
Irreverent jokes aside, Amedeo and Beatrice
fell deeply and sincerely in love.
It wouldn’t take long for Amedeo to propose.
On one hand, he would have much loved to speed
up proceedings, but he would not marry her
yet.
A recent law forbade promotions for unmarried
officers.
This was meant as an incentive for young men
to marry and reproduce for the growth of the
nation.
Guillet was well-aware of the law.
He stated that his sense of honour prevented
him from marrying Beatrice straight away -- he
knew that a promotion to 1st Lieutenant would
follow suit immediately.
And it would look as though he was marrying
her only for that reason!
His plan B was to seek another war and earn
a promotion on the battlefield.
Only then, he would marry Beatrice.
That seems a total rational way to plan a
wedding.
The occasion came with the start of Civil
War in Spain.
Fascist Italy and Nazi Germany participated
in that conflict by providing troops and equipment
to the Nationalist side led by Generalisimo
Francisco Franco.
And so, in the summer of 1937, Guillet volunteered
to lead a detachment of Italian ‘Arditi’,
or storm troops.
I should specify at this point that Guillet
was never a full supporter of Fascism.
All his military exploits were, and would
always be, related to a sense of duty toward
the King Victor Emmanuel III and the ruling
House of Savoy.
His participation in the Spanish Civil War
was borne of personal considerations, although
he later declared that he could not stand
the idea of a Communist Spain.
He soon got in the thick of the action.
Assigned to an Italian division known as “The
Black Flames”, he participated in the Battle
of Santander, August 1937.
This was part of Franco’s campaign to crush
Republican resistance in the North.
Guillet led his men to the assault on the
stronghold of San Pedro.
Despite stiff resistance, Amedeo succeeded
in storming the Republicans, and this opened
the doors to the advance on Santander.
The next big battle was Teruel, in the North
West.
In this occasion Guillet led a squadron of
Moroccan cavalrymen.
On an assault against a motorised column,
he suffered serious shrapnel wounds, but he
gritted his teeth and dispersed the enemy
unit, succeeding in capturing three Russian
armoured cars and their crews.
After eight months he had earned his battlefield
promotion and a military decoration from Franco
himself.
But he had also received a bad leg wound,
meaning his Spanish adventure was over.
While recovering in a military hospital in
Tripoli, he reflected on the atrocities he
had witnessed on both sides of the conflict.
In particular, he was very vocal with his
colleagues about the deplorable conduct of
the Germans.
At the end of 1938, Guillet had become good
friends with a Libyan girl, a young medical
student he had met at the hospital.
She was looking forward to her graduation
but there was a problem: she was Jewish, and
the recently approved Racial Laws in Italy
demanded for her to leave University.
These laws were a consequence of the increasingly
tight bond between Rome and Berlin, as Italian
Fascism did not have an anti-Semitic component
at its inception.
Guillet appealed to the Governor of Libya,
Air Marshal Italo Balbo, but all was in vain.
That was another blow dealt to Guillet’s
shaky confidence in Mussolini’s government.
The Devil Commander
With growing disgust for the political developments
in Rome, Guillet asked for his next posting
to be in Africa.
Luckily for him, in 1939 a family acquaintance
had been appointed as the new Viceroy for
the East African colonies.
This was his namesake Amedeo, Duke of Aosta,
a cousin of the King.
He had been appointed viceroy with the difficult
task of pacifying Abyssinia after the conquest.
Ethiopian guerrilla fighters, loyal to Emperor
Hailé Selassié, were still very active in
1939 and the Duke of Aosta thought men like
Guillet were the answer.
So, our protagonist was given command of a
unit called the “Group of Amhara bands,”
a multi-ethnic cavalry force which included
Ethiopian, Eritrean and Yemeni soldiers, led
by Italian officers.
Guillet and the ‘Amharas’ were given total
autonomy and freedom of movement to eradicate
guerrillas which had now spread into Eritrea.
It was during one of these actions that the
Amharas dubbed their leader ‘The Devil Commander’.
After a long series of skirmishes with the
guerrillas in the Dougur Duba region, Guillet
succeeded in luring them into a clash in an
open, flat territory, where he knew his horsemen
would be at an advantage.
Lieutenant Guillet led a charge against a
group of enemies: the attack was successful,
but his horse was shot from under him.
Guillet immediately requested a second horse
and charged again.
Once more, another enemy formation was routed,
once more, the poor horse was shot down, but
Guillet was unscathed.
We like to think at this point that all spare
horses now looked at each other, nodded, and
decided to quietly leave the battlefield unnoticed.
While they were doing that, Guillet seized
control of a machine gun position, turned
it towards the remaining rebels and wiped
them out single-handedly.
As a result of this action, Guillet’s superiors
awarded him the Silver Medal for Military
Valour – the 2nd highest military decoration
in the Italian Army.
Guillet’s colonial troops instead bestowed
on him a higher honour: the nickname of “Devil
Commander,” indicative of his fiery fighting
spirit and apparent immortality.
In later life, when recounting this event,
Guillet defined himself as
“the luckiest man I have ever known”.
I am sure his horses begged to disagree.
The last charge
In early 1940, Guillet made friends with an
Ethiopian Muslim chieftain, in his efforts
to pacify Eritrea and Northern Abyssinia.
Generally, Muslim locals tended to side with
the Italians, while Christians were staunch
supporters of the Negus -- the Ethiopian leader.
Lieutenant Amedeo also became friends with
the young, intelligent and beautiful daughter
of the chieftain, Khadija.
When Guillet asked her what did she want to
do in life, she replied
‘I am going to marry a chief and be at his
side’
But she had not chosen the chief yet.
When Guillet left the village with his Bands,
he was surprised to see Khadija riding out
to meet him.
‘I made my choice,’ she said.
‘You are the chief I want to be with!’
Guillet’s initial resistance was futile
and Khadija soon became his lover.
Amedeo’s soul was understandably torn between
the beautiful Ethiopian and Beatrice back
home.
When, on the 10th of June 1940 Mussolini declared
war on France and the United Kingdom, the
whole of Italian East Africa found itself
isolated from the motherland.
With little hope of seeing Beatrice again,
Amedeo deepened his relationship with Khadija,
who would follow him on the front lines in
many occasions.
The Duke of Aosta’s war against the British
and the French in East Africa started well,
with his troops occupying British Somaliland
and border territories with Kenya and Sudan.
However, total isolation meant lack of supplies,
including fuel for tanks and planes.
Very soon Aosta had to employ a defensive
strategy: fortifying mountain top redoubts
to resist Allied advance as long as possible.
One of these strongholds was Keren, which
guarded the road to Asmara, the colonial capital
of Eritrea.
In January 1941, the Italian garrison at Keren
desperately needed to buy some time against
the advance of the ‘Gazelle Force’, an
Anglo-Indian motorised and mechanised column.
Desperate situations call for desperate measures,
and desperate measures require men with courage,
luck, and a moustache so stiff it can deflect
shrapnel.
On the morning of the 21st of January, the
troops of the Gazelle Force were taking a
break, brewing tea in the gorge of Keru.
Suddenly a shout broke the morning silence:
“Savoia!”
It was Guillet’s battle cry.
Dressed in Arab clothes and riding his favourite
horse Sandor, the Devil Commander was leading
a charge of 250 Eritrean horsemen.
The charge cut through a Sikh regiment, flanked
a column of armoured cars and then galloped
straight towards the British artillery.
Guillet and his men attacked the armoured
plates of the enemy with what they had: pistols,
swords and hand grenades.
As these troops were Anglo-Indian, they described
the grenades as
“flying like cricket balls"
The defenders, taken completely by surprise,
were cut down by swords and shrapnel.
Guillet’s squadrons rode through the column,
regrouped and then launched a second charge.
But this time the Gazelle troops were ready,
they trained their guns and fired at point
blank range, cutting through the galloping
horses, but also causing friendly fire damage,
as the shells exploded amid the Sikhs and
the armoured cars.
After a few more seconds the horsemen disappeared
into the network of gorges of the Eritrean
landscape.
Guillet had dared the unthinkable: a cavalry
charge against a mechanized column.
Was it worth it?
The raiders’ loss was great – perhaps
half their men – but the damage they inflicted
gave an important breather to their fellow
troops at Keren.
The charge at Keru would be the last cavalry
charge faced by the British Army, with many
soldiers declaring it the most frightening
and extraordinary episode of the Second World
War.
A Private War
Guillet knew well that this was a war started
for the wrong reasons, and fought with inadequate
resources.
He continued the fight in two further battles,
Coken and Teclesan, until Asmara fell to Commonwealth
troops on the 1st of April 1941.
Two days later, the now-Captain Guillet made
a harsh decision.
He would disobey orders to surrender to the
British and continue with a war of his own,
a private war.
With Khadija by his side, he gathered 100
of his best riders and organised them into
an effective guerrilla fighting force.
His aim was to pin down in Eritrea as many
British troops as possible, to prevent them
from joining other theatres in Abyssinia,
Egypt and Libya.
The Devil Commander discarded his regular
uniform, donned Arab clothes and even changed
his name to a new Yemeni identity, Ahmed Abdallah
Al Redai.
His embrace of Arab customs and asymmetric
war against a powerful Empire would earn him
the nickname of ‘The Italian Lawrence of
Arabia’ after the war.
Over the course of eight months, Guillet and
his guerrillas raided trains, convoys and,
armouries.
They blew up roads, bridges, and galleries.
They cut down telegraph and telephone lines,
harassing British communication and logistics
lines.
Two British intelligence officers were given
the task to apprehend him: Major Max Harrari,
and Captain Sigismund Reich.
Harrari would become a close friend of Guillet’s
after the War, but for the moment he was driven
to get rid of this nuisance: he offered a
reward of 1,000 Pounds - dead or alive.
Yet, nobody reported him to the British authorities.
Until one day, an Arab farm hand walked into
the British headquarters in Asmara and gave
precise directions as to where they could
find the Devil Commander and his band.
The man pocketed a reward and walked away,
while Harrari’s men set off to finally seize
the stubborn cavalryman.
Who was that farm hand?
Well, he was none other than Guillet in disguise.
He succeeded in throwing a red herring sending
Harrari on a wild chase, while raising more
funds to his cause along the way.
What a sneaky devil.
But his luck could not go on forever.
Action after action, the ranks of his band
grew thinner.
Even his faithful steed Sandor was captured
by Harrari’s men.
On one occasion, the farm where he was hiding
was surrounded by the British.
In his Yemeni disguise, he jumped from a window
and simply walked away from the encirclement,
ignoring the soldiers’ calls to stop and
identify himself.
A quick-thinking Eritrean saved him by telling
the British that that guy was a deaf Arab
peasant and to leave him alone.
With the band reduced to 30 men, and a bad
ankle wound, Guillet decided he should not
ask more sacrifices from his riders.
He disbanded the private army, sent Khadija
back to her father and decided to retreat
to Yemen, with just one comrade by his side,
Dhaifallah.
Guillet and Dhaifallah travelled to the port
of Massawa and paid a hefty sum to some smugglers
to take them to Yemen.
But the luckiest man in the world was in for
a big surprise: the smugglers did not sail
across the Red Sea, but instead dumped them
on a desert shore some miles south of Massawa.
The two adventurers were almost dead from
thirst, when some goatherds approached in
the distance.
They would have surely helped the luckiest
man in the World and his friend!
They didn’t.
The goatherds attacked them, beat them senseless,
stripped them of all belongings and left them
for dead in the desert.
Luck finally came knocking, in the shape of
a travelling merchant, who picked the two
up and sheltered them until they had recovered.
With the merchant’s help, Guillet finally
reached the Yemeni port of Hodeida in December
1941.
When questioned, Guillet revealed his identity
and asked for refuge in Yemen.
After a brief stint in prison, Guillet was
summoned to the capital Sana’a, where he
met the local ruler Imam Yahya, who declared
himself a friend of Italy.
The Imam welcomed Guillet in his household,
while the officer made himself useful by training
Yahya’s bodyguards and even treating an
outbreak of cattle sickness.
Luck was again back on his side, but what
of the war?
Homecoming
In mid-1943 news reached Guillet of British
plans to repatriate Italian civilians and
wounded servicemen from Eritrea with a Red
Cross ship.
The reward on his head was still standing,
so he had to sneak on board and travel as
a stowaway.
In early September 1943, he was finally back
in Rome.
By now a Major, Guillet demanded men, weapons
and money to resume guerrilla actions in East
Africa.
But on the 8th of that month news broke out
of an armistice signed by King Victor Emmanuel
III with the Allies.
This armistice effectively split Italy in
two: to put it simply, Fascist loyalists regrouped
in the North and continued the fight alongside
the Germans.
While monarchists like Guillet and anti-fascists
formed a co-belligerent army in the South,
siding with the Allies.
Guillet was assigned to the intelligence services
of the co-belligerents, performing several
secret missions in Axis-controlled territory,
of which little is known.
Of this period of his life we can certainly
claim that he finally married Beatrice in
September 1944.
Guillet’s last action as a spy took place
immediately after the end of the War in Italy,
on the 25th of April 1945.
A Brigade of the resistance had stolen from
Fascist officials the Imperial Crown of the
Negus Hailé Selassié.
Returning the crown to the Ethiopian ruler
was key to re-establish a peaceful relationship
with that country.
Guillet staged a daring heist to retrieve
the crown from the partisans and was then
assigned to personally take it back to Ethiopia.
He took the occasion to meet with Khadija
one last time.
During this tearful reunion, he gave her a
gift – not from him, but from his wife.
Surprisingly, Beatrice knew everything about
Khadija and was very understanding.
She wanted Khadija to receive a family heirloom
of hers, a beautiful bracelet, to thank her
for taking care of her Amedeo during his dangerous
adventures.
After the War
On the 2nd of June 1946 a referendum abolished
the Monarchy in Italy, which became a Republic.
Guillet decided he would rather not be an
officer in a republican Italy and retired
with the rank of Colonel.
His next career would be in the diplomatic
service.
Due to his knowledge of Arabic, his postings
would be mostly in Middle Eastern and North
African countries, which gave him the occasion
to meet again some of his old friends.
For example, in the 1950s he was working in
the Italian Embassy in Yemen, where he was
reunited with Dhaifallah.
He returned to Sana’a in September 1962
to attend the funeral of the ruler Imam Ahmad.
By coincidence, the same night a coup was
taking place against the new imam, Al-Badr.
Guillet woke up in his room to find Al-Badr
and his followers as they were loading their
weapons.
As the conspirators approached he helped them
escape from the window of his room.
As you can see, a diplomat’s life is not
all about entertaining with pyramids of Ferrero
Rocher chocolates.
In 1967, Guillet was the Ambassador in Morocco.
During an official party he was attending,
a coup was launched against King Hassan.
When a firefight broke out, Guillet, almost
60, sprang into action and managed to save
several guests from the cross-fire, including
the German Ambassador.
The West German government awarded him the
Grand Cross of the Order of Merit of the Republic.
It is safe to say that the luckiest man in
the World was by no means a lucky charm, neither
to horses nor to Arab monarchs.
The same retired official who spoke to us
about ‘Black Prince’ Junio Valerio Borghese
some months ago, also had the chance to meet
Baron Guillet.
He told us that while serving in Morocco,
Guillet liked to take visiting dignitaries
for a tour of the souk, or market, of Rabat.
To do so, he would disguise himself as a local
and engage in intense shouting and haggling
matches in Arabic with the vendors.
On one occasion Guillet and the vendor shouted
so loud that it looked as though they would
come to blows.
Apparently, Guillet had insinuated that the
vendor was the son of a dog and a lady of
the night, to put it mildly.
Then, suddenly, they burst out in laughter
and embraced each other.
Guillet got away with paying a fraction of
the asking price.
In 1975, following his final appointment as
Italian ambassador in Delhi, Amedeo Guillet
and his wife retired to County Meath, Ireland.
After the death of Beatrice in 1990, the former
Devil Commander returned to Rome.
In the year 2000, aged 91, Guillet traveled
to Eritrea for the last time, in order to
revisit the sites of his adventure with his
biographer Sebastian O'Kelly.
He was received with full honours by the Eritrean
government.
Time moved on and on the 16th of June 2010,
aged 101, after a life of battles and charges,
of bullet, shrapnel and sword wounds, Amedeo
Guillet finally raised the white flag and
gave in to death.
Some of our more faithful viewers may have
noticed some similarities with another remarkable
military leader we have covered, Adrian Carton
de Wiart.
Both Amedeo and Adrian
Were born soldiers, always looking for another
war to fight in
Were cavalry officers
Suffered a great deal of wounds but never
gave up
Had a certain degree of madness
Sported enviable ‘taches
Went from military to diplomatic duties
Retired in Ireland
Adrian was 29 years older than Amedeo and
died eight years before the Devil Commander
moved to Ireland, so it is fair to say they
never met.
But what if for a twist of fate these two
former enemies met in retirement and became
friends?
What shenanigans would they have been up to?
Post your scenarios or even micro-short-stories
in the comments … and as usual, thank you
for watching!